hey guys it's justine and today we're
going to be talking about some of my
favorite features in big sur this is the
latest
update to mac os that will be coming out
later this fall but the public beta is
out now so if you do want to check it
out make sure you back up your computer
or put it on a secondary device you can
find the link and all the information to
download at apple's public beta website
so first before we get into this a huge
thank you to dbrand for sponsoring this
video i'm such a huge fan of their skins
and they just came out with
these beauties they have an all new
pastel lines you can get these for your
computer
for your phone they even have this
really cool rubik's cube you can check
out their website and see all the
devices that they support and i have a
feeling that you're going to find
something that you love and i'm so
excited about
these pastel colors normally i have
their pink skins on all of my devices i
thought i would do a little different of
a color scheme
this is what i decided to go with for my
macbook my phone
and my ipad if pastel isn't your thing
they do have tons of other colors and
options and textures
they also have these really cool grip
cases which i have on right now and you
can customize this
to be any color as well it has little
grippy sides
clicky buttons it's also impact
resistant up to nine feet which is
incredible because we all know i drop my
phone way too many times a day
i'm also really excited about this
rubik's cube which is kind of unique
because
it does have some of their pastel colors
on it and when i got this in the mail i
thought i've never actually tried to
solve a rubik's cube and i have no idea
how well after watching a few youtube
tutorials
and shortly after realizing that
these colors don't actually align with
the real rubik's cube colors
purple is actually the color yellow now
that i can solve it under three minutes
i'm gonna try to
maybe speed up my skills a little bit
this is a really fun quarantine hobby if
anybody hasn't tried
i'll put a link in the description if
you want to check out dbrand and all of
the awesome skins that they have
available
and now my friends it is time to talk
about big sur i actually went to big sur
last month it was the first time that i
had left the house at all
i came out of quarantine i was like i
need to go somewhere
you guys i have big sur
on my lap while i'm in big sur behind me
is the bixby bridge and this is one of
the most iconic bridges
and it's even on the desktop background
it's so cool i got my mask back on
because there's a lot of people around
but this is amazing and i planned on
making the whole video here
but there's a lot of people so i think
i'm just gonna get some b-roll and
i'll go home and talk to you guys about
big sur i've got my dbrand skin on
so it's uh i don't know it's a vibe
[Music]
so the biggest update to big sur is the
design everything is now
very seamless with ios like at some
point i started
reaching in to touch my screen and
nothing happened the icons are now much
more uniform
the menu is more of a transparent kind
of look so it's way more seamless
integrated into the background now a
10-day history for battery life which i
think is kind of cool because you'll be
able to go back and see what apps have
been kind of sucking the life out of
your computer
the toolbars and sidebars have all been
redesigned to blend in better with each
window
the windows have a lighter design softer
more rounded edges
like i said the icons have also been
redesigned something else that's really
cool
is this now has the startup chime you
guys might remember this chime
well they removed that around 2016 or so
and i forgot that that was an update in
this mac os big sur when it happened i
was like
what are you doing the notification
center has a new redesign so when you go
into your notifications
you'll be able to see the notifications
mixed with the widgets so all of this
feels
so much like ios 14 but it's kind of
crazy because this is kind of what
your notifications look like when you're
on your iphone with the version of ios
14 and it even has a control center so
much like the control center on your
phone you can do things like turn the
wi-fi
off bluetooth airdrop set do not disturb
you can adjust your display your sounds
and i don't really know how else to
explain it except it's like control
center in ios
and i love it the thing that i'm most
excited about though in this update is
messages now much like ios 14
again i feel like i keep going back to
ios 14 because there's so many
similarities and crossovers here
that you can do a lot of things that you
can do on that update as well so things
like pinned messages you can pin up to
nine conversations and that will carry
over from ios to your computer to your
ipad so it's all very seamless
and inside of those pin conversations if
there's group conversations
you can now add an emoji or an image to
those conversations
and of course you can also change the
name i feel like a lot of times most of
my group conversations are just people
changing the name to funny things and
then i can't ever find that group
conversation because people will change
the name and i won't even realize it i'm
like where is that converse i know we
were just having a chat to make group
conversations a little bit easier they
have
inline responses but i feel like for
group messages
this is going to be wildly useful so if
somebody else is talking about something
you can then go in and click into that
specific message
and then have a separate conversation
under it i'm surprised it took them this
long
i don't care how long it took i'm just
glad it's here if you've ever tried to
search in messages
it's not a good experience at all i
don't really know how else to say it
it's not good but they do have an
updated search so this will help you
find conversations photos links much
easier
than you could previously i use imessage
so much for so many different things
like video changes
sharing files back and forth instead of
even using email another big update
is safari so what's really cool about
this is they've integrated a lot of
privacy features so inside the privacy
control center you can kind of click
into it and this will show you how many
trackers
have tried to track you and how many of
those it's blocked this is cool because
i think a lot of us
just surf the web not really considering
the privacy aspect of
what's happening we're just you know
mindlessly searching shopping whatever
so with this it'll let you know
exactly where you've been and what has
been blocked i use
tabs a lot like sometimes way too much
way too many tabs are open so you can
now
preview a tab instead of having to click
into it i think that's pretty awesome
because i'll have so many tabs open that
i won't remember which one i'm actually
looking for so now you can quickly go
through and highlight over it and you'll
be able to see a preview of it they've
made it easy so you can migrate
extensions from other browsers you can
also transfer over your browser history
your passwords and all of that stuff
so if you weren't using safari before
and you were using say chrome they're
like hey let's just make it easy for you
to come on back over here you also have
built-in translation
on safari 4k youtube viewing
freaking finally that's actually
supported in mac os catalina so
that's going to be carrying over
obviously to big sur so they did a huge
update to maps and they brought a lot of
the features that they had in ios over
to the desktop version which i don't
really use
maps on my computer that often i think
one of the things that i would
use on the computer in maps is when
we're allowed to travel
again they have these really cool things
called guides and these are curated by
brands and trusted people
to give you the best places to shop to
eat or to visit so this is going to be
really neat when we can leave the house
again i do like that if you're a cyclist
this will now give you cycling
directions it'll give you elevation
if you want to avoid busy roads or
stairs it'll give you those different
routes
and you can also send that right to your
phone too and if you have an electric
vehicle which i don't have yet but i
really really really want to get one in
the future getting one now was kind of
pointless because i don't really go
anywhere
you can use the new maps to get guided
directions to route you to places that
you can charge your electric vehicles so
be able to find those charging stations
the app store is getting a big update
they're calling it the nutrition label
so various apps will be able to have a
rating you'll be able to figure out
exactly what information they're
gathering what they're sharing so that's
gonna be really helpful because i feel
like obviously with all of the tick tock
drama right now so having an upfront
knowledge of what those apps are
actually doing in the background
is it long overdue actually so if you
have
your phone in your mac running on the
latest ios updates with big sur and ios
14 you'll be able to have automatic
switching between
the two devices with airpods which is
going to be really great because when i
used to travel a lot on flights i'd be
going from my computer to my phone
back to my computer so being able to
have that seamless transition is going
to be
really cool home kit is getting secure
video cameras
you can view those right in the home app
the release will be coming out later
this fall and like i said
the public beta is out but if you do
decide to download this make sure you
see if your computer is compatible with
it and if you do plan on installing
please make sure you back up your mac
just in case something happens it is a
beta so it's not a full release so i
guess that's it if you guys are new to
my channel be sure to subscribe and hit
the bell if you aren't new here
hello hi i'll see you guys in the next
video bye
you